in this lineup but I think that's just how they
are especially this guy here with the puck BR
aolia drive and that's off the leg of Tristan jari
Mikey McLoud elevated into a higher rooll with
all those guys out but a turnover and Crosby the
other way three onone for the pens Crosby looking
for help in front get so had it knocked off his
stick and then gets clobbered by Sean ther just
a little bit behind [Applause] Rebels back in
Hamilton's pass picked off by Graves and ahead
come the pens another two on one Smith holding it
Crosby shoots it and a save made by vanich Crosby
up top one time or Carlson and vanich snares it
Max Wilman who a couple games ago became the 66
we like that number player in Devil's history to
score in his New Jersey debut had a great year a
dangerous skilled fast team here's jesser brat
centering it down on M cloud back in jar Great
Stop in tight a guy named Stevens I don't know
if you heard of him play for the Penguins pretty
good co here's a chance poot off a loose puck in
front good keep at the line Pon for Crosby back to
Marcus Pon and a shot of stop rebound it wouldn't
go did vanich keep that out how if he did that's
one of the more ridiculous saves you'll see gel
Point Blank at top the crease and couldn't put
it in Great Net fun presence here's rust racing
back in backhander [Applause] [Music] scares well
he's not stopping that one Brian rust upstairs and
the Pens have the first goal once again and then
right back the other way Brian rust all kinds of
speed down that Wing gives him a little shoulder
drop shoulders on the number seven minutes gone
here in this first period as jari makes a good
stop on McLoud there in tight rido able to get
it to Raquel who Banks it to the neutral zone
Bey Hamilton a Miss play and the puck rolls in on
vanich able to keep it out and then in a goose egg
since yeah everyone got going pretty good here
he is with a chance to score and jari makes a
great stop Point Blank Crosby back to Russ nice
pass looking in Bron gel couldn't connect here's
L Tang a shot pinballs to the net save B it's
loose and Bach grabs the loose Puck but we have
a penalty at ice level we get a look right here
at the Penguins do some great board work that's
that little pop play little 10- foot play as Russ
just kind of jumps to a hole and three and he can
motor Mike McLoud one-on-one with Carlson and
it off the hollow with a shot a stick save by
jari Sean thaler Springs Mercer a minute left
but he's short-handed backhander and that went
up over the net jar may have gotten a piece the
pens since then haven't been able to really oh
there's another one another turnover this two on
one holla Lazar carrying shooting scoring just
a matter of time the Devils controlling it from
a short-handed perspective and Curtis Zars tied
the game and one just a good read right there
they're stepping up they're poking pucks and
they're gone holla again finds Lazar some good
patience just hangs on to it he looked like he
was running out of real estate finds a five hole
on jari short-handed even the score 1-1 back the
puck deep in the devil Zone able to get it to Drew
o Conor fresh on the ice his shots blocked oconor
smacks it to the net deflected wide by [Applause]
Malin trying to build something right off the Hop
here the Devils though out to Center here's just
for brat tied for the team lead with 20 points
moves around Carlson Brad and he's stopped by
jari jari had to be sharp here early on this
fresh ice look at that little hip swivel by Brad
he's so good on his edges skilled to he's out to
the neutral zone it's gensel nice pass to Crosby
he rolls in passing for Carlson on the backand
throws it to the net save and it the books and
they [Applause] score the pens go back in front
as Carlson put that to the goal did Brian Russ tap
it in Crosby enters the Zone look at that finds
Carlson he was going to move it and then decided
not to amazing through the legs of gensel but
rust is right there that little touch and it just
squeaks through vanich well Kyle dubis mentioned
in conversations that rust was the highest testing
physical fitness player in training camp preseason
workouts as a chance in front is put in and
Bastion evens it back up less than two minutes
later a little bit of a dagger but it's
the Devils as they come back on up ice
and transition on Entry puck gets through the
jar he just bunts it back out in front it just
hits him and springs loose and there's Eric
Holla he's been all over the ice it's hard
to believe he's only 31 and he can score goals
that's why they got him here they got guys that
can make plays he's a goal scorer Smith with a
Chance off the end wall getting across quickly
was vanich lost an edge behind the net brat
twisting with it shooting save J rebound he
got that one too from fley 778 to 645 that's
always one I would hold over my brother for
sure you got to do it you got to both hard knows
good hockey players Devil's back in one Tim from
Miller and a glove save jari sees it the whole
way and there's no rebound I was going to say
he's been uh dealing with a lot of traffic a
lot of body 18 seconds and Crosby's out of the
box but the Pens have the puck here canel turning
and shooting that's blocked Lazar for brat Hughes
moves around gensel here comes Luke Hughes to J
for brat holding shooting scoring oh brat with a
beauty that goes upstairs on jari and the Devils
have their first lead of the night four on four
little open Ice nice play by Luke Hughes to
get free right here then look at that little
hip swivel to generate speed off of that we saw
him earlier in the game get a chance and jari
just beat him to that post well here it is uses
his skating again to get a little bit free lost
it over the attacking line Carlson gets it back
still 14 seconds on the power play here's Malin
with it across Smith rips it save van ack you
look at this pass by Gino just straight across
east to west just toesy newes looking him fly
in on the attack sliding across Iaria huge stop
on Holtz looking for help hit by Eller shrugs off
that check a chance in front they score beautiful
passing play as Holt slam dunk a top the grease
and it's 4-2 what a play up the ice oh it was a
look pass but just back across the grain here's
poot draws people into him and then Mercer guy
who missed that pass to a breaking forward put
a 10t ahead of him this time with a chance and
look at the touch of that just to get over the
backside of the net strange caram will play on
As the Devils get it to center now New Jersey
with a two- goal lead looking for more here
comes the B he scores and the Devils have broken
this game wide open three goals in the third 5-2
New [Applause] Jersey career year and goals last
year this is why they got them they stretched the
new Zone BRS right up by the blue line they get
out in a hurry these Devils just a perfect pass
and a perfect shot fulia pure goal scorer and
just like that back to Tyler T Foley and the
Devils have ended the Penguins winning streak with
a 5-2 victory here tonight at PPG paint Serena